well let's talk now to the leader of the
opposition secure who joins us now thank
you very much for being here uh with us
uh good to have you on the programme um
let's start with the local elections uh
shall we what would success look like
well we've got a really good team of
candidates we've got a very positive
message we're
laser liking our focus on the issue that
matters the cost of living
crisis and we want to make gains we want
to hold the good seats that we've got we
want to make gains and so we go in a
very positive spirit i don't want to
predict what's going to happen but the
teams are in good shape and i can tell
you the cost of living issue is the
number one issue and
um the conversations that we've been
having wherever we are in the united
kingdom
are essentially people saying to us
i can't afford to pay my bills and i've
just got whacked for more tax by the
government the government has
response to the cost of living trust
been an abject failure
and we've got a very positive uh
proposition to put on the table so what
we're saying in these elections is send
a message to the government about their
total and abject failure in relation to
cost of living
vote for a party that's got an
alternative a plan to deal with what
matters most the thing that's keeping
you up at night um and vote for a party
that's on your side okay that's the uh
pitch um you say you wanna make your
game that's the argument we've been
making across the country for the last i
don't know how many weeks but it's great
to be out there making that argument um
so you say you want to make gains could
some of those gains come in scotland do
you think you might leapfrog the
conservatives to come second there to
the snp well i've just come back from
scotland so i was up in scotland on
thursday and friday with anasawa our
brilliant leader up there
the team up there are in positive
spirits there have been some recent
suggestions that
we might overtake the conservatives i'm
very conscious that whether it's in
scotland or anywhere else in the country
we have to earn every vote i'm not
taking anything for granted um i know
that we've got a lot of work to do from
where we landed in the last general
election
but we're working hard on this and i
think the main reason for that is
because
we have this very practical
response to the cost of living crisis
which is to say look oil and gas
companies in the north sea have made
more profit than they're expecting we
should tax that and use it towards
energy bills take up to 600 pounds off
for those that most need it okay and
don't impose a tax uh in the middle of a
cost of living crisis we'll talk a
little bit more like that positive we'll
talk a bit more about the vision in a
minute um but you know you're saying
that you started from a low base uh
after the last election results i think
everyone would agree with that at the
same time though you know the time that
most of these suits were last fought was
under jeremy corbyn in that time we've
seen a prime minister who has been fined
for breaking the law we've seen a
conservative mp this week you had to
resign after being caught watching
pornography in the house of commons
we've seen as you've been talking about
a cost of living crisis you shouldn't
just be hoping to make a few gains
should you shouldn't you be absolutely
storming ahead of the conservatives in
the polls and why aren't you well look
they are the dying groans of a sort of
clapped out government i certainly
accept that whether it's owen patterson
and the scandal there whether it's
partygate whether it's the sleaze that
they say so why aren't you smashing them
in the polls well what we've done we've
gone when i took over which was whatever
it was two years just over two years ago
we were over 20 points behind in the
polls and we'd lost a general election
the worst loss for us since 1935 and in
two years we turned the labour party
around we've changed the labour party
nobody suggests that we haven't and
we've got ourselves into a position
where we've now got a poll lead so now
i'm just talking about perhaps being
able to make a few gains from where
jeremy corbyn did in 2018. in two years
that's a pretty extraordinary
progress
we've got wind in our sails we're a
confident team i've got a fantastic
front bench out there now obviously you
know when the next general election
comes whether it's next year or the year
after we've got more work to do into
there but to have gone from where we
were when i picked up the labour party
and the leadership of the labour party
to where we are now is considerable
progress more work to do of course we're
gonna we're gonna fight for every vote
in these general elections i go nowhere
expecting people to vote for labour
we've got to put our positive case on
the table say what we would do about the
cost of living crisis
and i have scoured all the papers this
morning as you would have done i didn't
see a single thing from the government
about what they're going to do about the
cost of living christmas let's talk
about that
let me just finish on the local
elections because the conservative
chairman has accused you of a secret
pact with the lib dems on the front page
of the mail on sunday you probably saw
it when you were scouring the paper i
did uh standing aside candidates where
the lib dems are strong and vice versa
to avoid splitting the n2 tory vote now
in the southwest
you're standing candidates in 61 of
seats compared to 97 in 2018. well look
um the first thing i'd say is i wouldn't
take anything oliver dowden says
particularly seriously and the fact that
he is spending his
sunday opportunity
um to speak to the public attacking
labour on some part why doesn't he say
something about cost of living crisis is
it is it true is it true i know you're
trying to
there's no there's no pact um everybody
knows uh there's no pack we will put a
candidate up um if there's a when there
is a by-election obviously after the
neil parish um resignation of yesterday
um but what we're doing is
candidates and seats such as in the
southwest i think and i'll happily have
this checked out that we are standing
more cat labor candidates in this
election than we've ever stood
um now i'm recalling a statistic in the
back of my mind but i'm pretty sure
we've got more candidates out there than
we've ever put in the field before we're
very you know we're out there i've got
teams working across the country we're
positive we're laser focused on the cost
of living crisis and all you've got from
the government is mud slinging left
right and center whether it's angela
rainer whether it's oliver dowd and
talking about pacquiao okay why aren't
they talking about the issue that
matters everybody knows that people are
worried about paying their bills what
what's the government got to say about
that absolutely nothing we're going to
tax you in the middle of a cost of
living crisis well let's let's talk
about that shall we because it's clear
that you want to talk about the cost of
living christ
i can tell that you want to get into the
number one issue
what is the number one thing you would
do to stop and i and and i know you're
going to rattle off you know a few
things such as you know
taxing all companies a bit more not
putting up national insurance by the
same amount paying you'd pay a bit less
on your energy bills due to the at cup
but i'm just wondering if these things
are
big enough to meet the challenge of what
we're about to face what is the big idea
to tackle it well the immediate problem
that many people are facing is that
their energy bills have gone up by
hundreds of pounds and
i've had i'm afraid too many examples of
the human impact of that a pensioner two
weeks ago with mobility problems aged 86
telling me that she's too scared to put
her central heating on because of the
bill and she's got a sort of padded
gown that she sits in most of the day so
that's the immediate problem what's the
government done about it absolutely
what's going on what's labour going to
do we're going to tax the oil and gas
companies in the north sea
in relation to their excess profit so
the profits they didn't expect to make
because the global price has been so
high and i hired quasi as wrong and what
are you going to do
then we're not talking about taxing the
profits they expected to make this is
the profits they didn't expect to make
we would then use that to reduce energy
bills by up to 600 pounds for those that
need it directly using that for the
energy bills now i can tell you this um
600 pounds
help with the energy bills for those
that need it would be desperately needed
and welcomed across the country we also
wouldn't introduce a tax a
self-defeating tax at the worst possible
time in the in the mid this week many
people have got their pay slip and
they'll have looked at that and saw well
the bills are going up the pay slip is
less because the government's just
whacked me for even more tax in a cost
of living crisis um and so we've got
practical answers to what is the number
one issue as i go around the country and
all of our teams reporting this all the
tory teams will be reporting this back
to them as well what do they say five
days to go before the election what have
they said about the cost of living today
absolutely nothing okay um i want to
play you a quick video uh it's an
endorsement that you've received uh
today
from uh tony blair i think it might be a
little bit controversial with some
people in the left of the party let's
just have a little quick look
in strength
determination and intelligence in
setting labor back on a winning path
he knows a labour party true to its
principles
is a labour party dedicated to winning
power
i mean someone on the left might be a
bit uncomfortable with this particular
endorsement
tony blair won three elections
and
the labour party
uh doesn't win elections very often so i
think having the endorsement of tony
blair is is very important very valuable
and and and i think
further demonstrates the amount of work
we've done in the last two years the
change that we've made but i'm very
happy to talk to and with someone who's
won three elections because i didn't
come into politics to be an opposition i
came into politics to win elections it's
strange because i remember interviewing
you during the leadership election and i
asked you if you thought you were
politically closer to jeremy corbyn or
to tony blair
now you wouldn't tell me you said i can
think myself i don't need to hug jeremy
corbyn i don't need to hug tony blair or
anyone else i have to say it feels a lot
like you're a lot more comfortable
hugging tony blair i can't imagine you
putting an endorsement video for jeremy
corbyn up you you took the whip off him
what i've said why didn't you say at the
time why weren't you honest to say yeah
actually i'm more close to tony what i
said at the time what i've said
consistently is um
the
team now that we've got or the
leadership team you've got going inside
the question
are you closer to tony blair or jeremy
let me just tell you what i said at the
time which was i'm not going to hug any
previous labour leader because i don't
believe that you go backwards to go
forward i will learn from any labour
leader i will talk with any labour
leader and if stania blair has won three
elections gordon brown who won it with
them then i'll happily take their advice
and talk with them but i've never been
but i've never suggested that we i think
tony actually in that endorsement or
something he said yesterday said we're
not in the nate in the 1990s we're
actually going to face the future going
forward so it's the principles and
approach that matter but i you know
i spend my time talking to people who
win because i want to win i want to win
because i want to change the lives of
millions of people
don't tell me that in the leadership
election they did you i've i think in
the leadership i can't remember how many
times leadership election
i said i think i use this phrase saying
i'm not going to have the name of some
previous labour leader tattooed on my
forehead i have to take this party
forward facing the challenge that we've
got now okay i can't i'm not facing the
challenges that tony blair faced a
quarter of a century ago um i'm not
facing the challenge that previous
leaders faced i'm facing the challenges
of tomorrow and i'm absolutely
determined okay to not only change the
labour party but to change britain in
the work that we're doing okay now i do
need to ask you about what happened in
durham
uh this is when you were pictured
drinking beer with party activists ahead
of a by-election at the time of course
people in england were banned from uh
mixing indoors apart from
at work there's a picture though yeah
lots of coverage of this
was angela rainer there yes
um we were
in the office we were working we paused
for something to eat there was no party
no rules were broken uh and that is the
long and the short of it and durham
police looked at it and decided there
was absolutely nothing wrong what we've
seen this week is lots of just we've got
an election now i know what's going on
here we've got election on thursday what
is going on and there's just tory mps
now that's trying to throw mud around
because they've got nothing to say on
the central issue of the cost living if
they focused as intensely on the cost of
living as they are on durham millions of
people would be saying you know good
thing too i understand your frustration
at this event being compared or or may
seem be equivalent to other lock-down
breaches i understand why struggle
that's the problem with it i struggle
look what i struggle with is why if
angela was there
you said that she wasn't there
let me just i don't i don't understand
why that would okay sophie it was a
mistake we made a mistake in the office
i get i guess it was a mistake it was a
general mistake why wasn't it corrected
well you see how it looks it just looks
a bit shifty even if it wasn't why
didn't you correct the mistake when you
realized we were asked twice um and
i didn't arrive we made a mistake before
until it came out this week it was a j
we're a busy office we made a mistake
it's a genuine mistake
um and and let me i i take
responsibility for it i run the office
we we simply made a mistake it's a
genuine mistake i don't think anybody
would seriously say
kia stamos team would lie to the media
about this we made a mistake
the media was told the wrong information
and it wasn't correct
so if it was a you can know this from
from running officers yourself from time
to time a mistake is made it's a genuine
mistake um and i take responsibility for
that okay
uh now i want to talk to you finally uh
before we end just a little bit about
the sexism uh in westminster that we've
seen uh over the like the last few weeks
according to the sunday times more than
50 mps facing allegations of sexual
misconduct after being reported to a
parliamentary watchdog more than 50. the
papers are full of allegations from
mps licking researchers faces to
mps watching pornography in the house of
commons what is going on
let me take that slightly in stages
because there's no denying when you reel
off a
series of um
examples like that that there's a
cultural issue that we have to get to
grips with and culture change has to be
led from and modeled from the top
uh we need to listen to women um and
i've spoken to a number of women in the
last few days about this and they are
very clear that
um whilst there does need to be culture
change
um those who are engaged in this sort of
activity whether it's
comments about angela rainer or whether
it's watching porn in the house of
commons
have to take responsibility we can't run
this argument somehow this high-pressure
cultured place place
take responsibility neil parish chose to
watch porn in parliament
tory mps chose to make disparaging
comments about andrew arena they've got
to take responsibility neil parish to be
fair has taken responsibility he's
resigned yeah well then the third thing
is political leadership because what
we've seen from this government time and
again is when one of their own gets into
a difficulty and a problem because
they've done something they shouldn't
have done whether it's owen paterson
whether it's the wakefield mp or whether
it's neil parish their first instinct is
to push it off into the long grass um
you know hide what's happening and that
is a political problem because a fish
rot from the head and there needs to be
political leadership on this as well and
we haven't seen that from the
conservatives talking about political
leadership and it's got to be quite
brief because i've been told in my year
that i'm out of time but i do want to
squeeze this last one in what actually
needs to happen should we be looking at
closing bars in parliament should we be
looking at what the speakers wants to
see mps perhaps not being able to
directly employ staff what actually
needs to happen behavioral change that
we all have to contribute to uh cultural
change taking responsibility
i understand all these words but but
what's
what specifically
needs to change well
where an individual um is involved in
these sorts of behaviors they need to
take absolute responsibility straight
away with neil parish no no but sorry
i'm just asking for like a specific
thing like like for example you know do
we need to look at the employment at
legislation well do we need to close
bars do we need quotas for female mps i
think i mean the speaker's suggesting
that some sort of review the independent
process we put in place is a good thing
and i'm supporting and supportive of
that um the speaker i think wants to
pull
parties together to see what else can be
done i'm very happy to participate in
that because we can't go on just with
these allegations coming out over and
over again it feels a bit frustrating to
me i have to say you and also quasi
quantum coming in lots of strong words
about misogyny but i just can't see any
actual practical suggestions for what
can change rather than like oh we need
to be better well
there are practical things i mean the
independent process is good we'll talk
to speak about what else can be done but
sophie when i've dealt with cultural
change before and i had to do this
within the crown prosecution service
i i learned that it has to be led from a
model from the top people look to the
political leadership see what approach
they're taking
and you know without that i think it's
very difficult to bring about change
thank you we're out of time kirsten
thank you very much for being on the
program today